so you're getting ready to do Leo from
Toledo yeah so when he filming this and
about filming it in about 11 weeks yeah
you can share yeah Mel plays a guy who
is suffering from a kind of waking
dementia which is he blacks out but he's
he's conscious he's awake and then he
just lose time so it's written in the
script that he just loses time which is
kind of great if your screen right go I
don't get past this [ __ ] oh he'll
just black out and he basically is
living as this guy named leo ward and he
has a encounter with these kind of local
let's call them local toughs
and he wakes up in the hospital and his
friend who's a sheriff is staring at him
and he's handcuffed and he rolls his the
admittance appraisal over and he's it
says Conrad Varrick and Conrad Varrick
was his name when he was a hit man for
the Kansas City mob and he's in witness
protection now and he's just giving up
the ghost so they know he's alive
they're coming for him it's Mel Gibson
is like Martin Riggs in his 60s with me
and Frank playing a Anderson Cooper like
hitman to come and get him yes and by
the way I'm saying that so Frank commits
to looking like Anderson Cooper like hit
man it's on right there bro no filming
no I want to look at that gives me [ __ ]
I'm gonna go remember no no we were at
the screening and I said he's handsome
I like Anderson Cooper just almost as
much as brass silver hair so you got
where you guys filming this is anyway
from Ohio
Scott where we filming this Ohio
Louisiana and you have more than 27 days
no 26 do you have any days guiding Scott
35 30 yeah but it's much real 30 dude so
it's not as much action